do you still remember what it was like
when you're first told that you're going
to be Indiana Jones it all happened in
one day Steven Spielberg called me and
he said I have a or I'm sorry George
Lucas called me and said I have
something I want you to read I said okay
George send it up to the house an hour
later a script arrived it took me one
hour to read the script I called back
George and I said I want to do this he
said go over and meet Stephen please I
went over to Steven's house and we sat
together for our two hours and we talked
about it and I was given the opportunity
there was a moment before this where I
was not involved and and the role was to
have gone to Tom Selleck but Tom Selleck
had another obligation that he had to
fulfill he had a television series that
he'd signed on to do thank you thank you
thank you for a great career